so here we have elite dangerous
we're now at Premium vita one it's a
game I've wanted to come back to from a
very long time so here we see just
coming up out of the into the space
station this big internal cylinder
cylindrical volume is an amazing size
and gravity is a fantastic thing so this
is slowly rotated to give artificial
gravity of about 0.1 gravities that's a
bit like gravity on the moon gravity is
a wonderful thing it enables us to do
everything from eat to walk around to go
to the toilet quite easy if you didn't
have gravity things float around in a
very dangerous way of someone sneezes
the sneeze stays in the air for a long
time and for when you're landing a
spaceship or moving cargo the cargo
stays put if you put it down on the
ground
but at 0.1 G a normal human can lift it
up so it's the best of both worlds so
that's why the space stations have been
designed this way here you see the
outside of station you see all the the
effect of the lights and the sort of the
docking bay you see that strange
wireframe cage sticking out from Jhon
gateway that actually proves really good
when you're aligning yourself but also
we're planning to ramp up it's not as
strong yet you know retuning it within
the through the alpha and also debater
now to make docking slightly easier so
the idea is there's an electromagnetic
field that just helps your ship conform
with the docking bay and but having said
that it's very interesting we've noticed
we are getting more and more cocky with
small ships this is an eagle one of the
ships that was new to alpha 4 and is
also in the premium vty
but it's actually a lot small on the
docking bay so actually you can do
loop-de-loops as you go help virtually
you know and it's watching Adam here
who's flying being being very cocky has
been very entertaining so now we're out
of the station if we go and look at the
galaxy map you'll see you can see the
galaxy in the background there and we
see the two hundred cubic light-years
that you've already got in the premium
data now and five systems ten stars as
you look around if we are we looking at
de hann which is where we are now if we
just do zoom out a little you'll see
some of the stars in the surrounding
area if you just pause there you can see
these are all visible systems and the
white circle is where we currently
restricted the premium beta because we
want to keep all the players together as
we used to gradually improve the scale
of the game we zoom out some more you
see some of the more the larger stars
and you start to see the shape of the
galaxy you can see all of the dust that
we've had to add to get the night sky to
look right but also it shows its
concentrated strongly in the Galactic
plane and we'll see in a bit what that
means to get so to get our night sky to
match we've typed in some hundred and
fifty thousand star systems around that
are all real so if we now zoom in to
Seoul for example we've got a search
function now so people can you can find
any system including those who vast got
systems named after them that they've
already done from the Kickstarter if we
look at the night sky around Seoul you
can see one of the pull downs is an
option to turn on the constellations
which we've got here so you see here the
plow shape and shape over there if we
now move our viewpoint slightly you can
see it changed shapes it distort and all
the constellations gradually distort
until they're completely unrecognizable
all you need to do for some of them is
travel maybe ten or so light-years and
it's it's changed beyond recognition and
in fact there's a website to do with
people have been playing on the premium
beta and on the Alpha showing
constellations they've named in the new
systems one of which looks like a teacup
if no sage well it does once you see one
someone said II say yes both it does and
the great thing here is just seeing how
much of it is centered around the Sun
now the Sun is on virtually on the
galactic plane and that's where all the
dust is
some of the systems you'll see a
sneak-peek that are outside the Galactic
plane so we come up out of this dust so
this the the galaxy is so much brighter
so much more vivid and it's like in an
aeroplane when you climb up out of the
cloud layer suddenly you can see a cross
to the galactic center and it's just so
much brighter okay so if we travel to
one of the other systems let's choose
Aaron in so this is an agricultural
system
so let's travel there but instead it's
also independent and we happen to know
that it's an area where there's some
conflict there is some pressure for
Aaron in to become a federal system so
they're fed him to go over so there's
lots of areas of constant conflict
around here now as a player we can sign
up as a mercenary
to either side for which you get money
and the great thing there is you can
determine ultimately who wins these
conflicts so it may well be people
sometimes they'll be uprisings where
people being oppressed that said they're
mining ore and it's keeping the price of
ore down but you could side with the
oppressors because actually you like the
spaceships being chief because cheap or
means cheap metals need to keep its
emotions so but obviously I think the
honorable thing to do would be to side
with the oppressed you know to maybe to
run guns to the rebels past the blockade
and what will happen is whichever side
wins will be decide that where most
players side so you can actually
determine who wins such a conflict here
we are you can see the system we've just
selected on the night sky now every one
of those dots is a real system you can
visit you see a renin the rounding the
one we selected hype selected already
highlighted and we're heading towards it
at full speed and you'll see as the
drive charges up with slowly getting
ready to you see the effect starting now
and now
- hyperspace here we go we sort of if we
gently look around we see all of them
this is the effect as you travel from
systems system
so here we are we arrived suddenly your
ship cools down as you arrive just one
of the effects and there we see the star
airing in glowing in the background now
we're still in supercruise which is this
is a mode where we're traveling we're
already traveling at about an eighth of
the speed of light what we're doing now
is selecting the conflict zone which is
where there's this battle between the
Federation and the local independence
they're rebels that are trying to keep
the system independent the great thing
with these conflicts is you know you can
just choose to side with one side or the
other side and the end result of that
will determine the outcome depending on
how many players side with each side
they you know let's say it's the rebel
uprising is that the the oppress that
they know the oppressor so that let's
say they're mining some ore or means
cheap metal and therefore cheap
spaceships so it may well be that a lot
of the players side with the oppressor
to keep the price of the ships down so
we can sign up to either side here as a
mercenary and earn money from it and
that's how we will determine this over
time so we see here on our hood these
orange lines are the orbit lines of the
systems all the planets and stars orbit
continuously in real time there have
even been people uploading you know the
alpha and beta backers uploading video
onto YouTube of stop-motion showing all
of the all of the moons and planets
moving oops
overshot they're a bit
so you can see the moon that this
conflict zone is in orbit above this is
an area where we have this concept of a
combat bond where either side can
request help for you for money and
that's what we're doing here
so we've got to be within about a
thousand kilometres - there we go to
disengage from supercruise so when
you're super cruising around a system
you sort of see all the bodies move
relatively you're traveling at huge
speeds and you can sort of drop out of
this sort of soft hyper space if you
like we're still in early sort of
premium beater if you like there are a
lot of more effects that we're gradually
going to be layering in we'd be able to
show that magnetic fields of planets so
you actually see them a much bigger from
the further distance just whilst you're
super cruising and the more super
cruising you are because what we're
actually doing is shrinking space to
make that possible so here we've joined
the combat we've chosen our side and you
see that the people on your side who
signed up on the same side are shown in
green and those who are on the opposite
side are shown in red who are actually
some of them attacking you you see them
flashing white on your scanner those are
the people are currently firing at you
so there we go using some missiles to
help take them out the best thing to do
is to use your lasers we've got a pair
of gimballed lasers here that means they
there's a slight towing gimbal days you
can fit a smaller gimbal blazer than a
fixed laser but actually it ends up
being more effective to have a gimbal
laser because you could hit them more
often we see the information on the left
with the ship we've targeted this one's
a Cobra we see its hull is at 88% and
he's now trying to get out of our gun
sights but I think we're gonna nail him
we're in an eagle which is a combat
leaning ship whereas a cobra is a fairly
general-purpose ship now you may have
seen his main thrusters flare red there
what he did there is he did you know
thrusters essentially an afterbirth
y-you-you overdrive your engines to
thrust more out of this you can also put
more power to different parts of your
ship you see we've got some bit more
power put into weapons and our engines
and systems are slightly reduced to do
the attack but what you'll feed fine
once that she'll start dropping will
switch more power into the systems to
balance it that out now in all of these
things you know the complexity of it
we're going to be honest we're gamers
and we're writing this game for
ourselves we want this level of
complexity but you don't have to do it
if you don't want to yeah when we first
play this and actually this is true of
the AIS as well the base level they are
it doesn't do anything
we wanted the base level area to be a
bit stupid and to try and run away his
first line of defense and then the more
sophisticated ions they actually you see
some of these in the
in combat zones like this used use the
afterburn and Lister thing in concert
with the other features episode ear
that's not good that's the downside of
signing up for these mercenary missions
now what I suggest we do now is have a
sneak peek of some of the things that
are coming in bills over the next weeks
and months ok so here we have our sneak
peek of an Orbis Space Station so this
is a much bigger much more expensive
station that people won't have seen
before this is coming in the next bill
that will put out it's as you see that
coriolis is much more like the central
not much bigger than the central part of
this station there's this huge area
rotating for 1g around it this huge sort
of steering wheel if you like going
around the central docking bay and
actually there's a secondary on this
particular station there's a secondary
wheel which is set at half a G because
that may well be a lot more comfortable
for people it was already a suggestion
that it's it's actually much easier on
the heart for example so if you're an
old person you will live longer if you
live in lower gravity so we're playing
around with that sort of thing also the
station's will change depending on the
system that it's orbiting we see here
that we've got a white star we've got
the sort of actinic white light we're
sort of whitey blue but also you see
there are big storage boxes on the back
of the station you know so an
agricultural world if grain needs to be
stored between harvests that's the sort
of place it would be stored and you're
ready for the ships to take away now
we're in a lake on type 9 which some of
you may see this is a trading leaning
ship so it's lightweight hull not too
many hard points but it's absolutely
huge it's got a cavernous cargo bay you
see into the ship here the the cockpit
itself is multi-story as well it's got
two other seats further down we can just
sort of see the edges of them here
it's a giant copies a bit like a crane
cab stuck on the front of a big box you
know it's not the most elegant of ships
but it's great for trading and speaking
of which we see the docking slot below
of this new station this is a system
that is some hundred light years away
from the system's we've been showing in
beta-1 and the if you look at the galaxy
in the background if we sort of been
around to see that you'll see the night
sky is quite different we're sort of now
a lot more out of the dust it's a lot
more vivid we can see some of the
background information more but you see
here as we come up to the galactic
center and you can see to the right
spreading and underneath us now you see
the earth-like world that the stations
in orbit around on the distant moon
behind it but also you see the galaxies
the whis penis of the galaxy burn lowers
and in the distance and we can also see
to the galactic center across these
clouds now we're out of them when it's
very much brighter than it was before
and actually way much much brighter than
night sky now this system seventeen
Draconis is a real systems and it should
really look like that and yes every dot
in that night sky is also going to be
correct okay here so we're going to try
and dock this lake on type nine which is
a big bus of a ship into the slot now
what's interesting with these larger
ships is they are a much tighter fit and
actually harder to dock we will be
introducing things like docking
computers over time but actually there
is something really great about the sort
of the skill-based element of docking
you do it quite good at it and you see
the framework sticking out here again as
with the other system will help align
the ship the idea is as an
electromagnetic field coming from those
that will just help avoid you crashing
so here we're docking with paradizoo
outpost in the 17 Rakosi system this is
an early look at this station so there
you will see a few lot issues which we
will will sort out there you didn't see
that
but there we go beautifully done knots
great not a scratch and there we can see
our docking bay ahead of us now we're
also going to change these so if a high
class system if you look around here
this is all very gray what you'd expect
from a sort of practical federal system
but there will be ones with tree-lined
avenues here and bright lights so it
will look truly truly beautiful you know
there's this sort of thing you might get
in I don't know sort of Apple Center
sort of white where everything's clean
and beautiful the nice thing I like
about the lake on is you can look down
through between your legs and also
notice now the controls move are they
afraid we didn't wanted to move them too
much there we are going to line the dot
up with the centre of the earth there we
go and then just gradually bring it in
okay so that ends up sneak peek at elite
dangerous things coming over the next
few weeks and months this is our e3
build the content of this though will be
in the next build we relief release to
the premium beta and alpha backers the
game is slated for the end of this
calendar year for full commercial
release but of course there will be lots
of releases to the beta backers and
between now and release so thank you for
listening